[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka mr. marvel and
this is the channel where we explain it
so you don't have to the spider-man far
from home trailer brings a wealth of new
possibilities into the MCU and since its
release yesterday fans have flooded the
internet with their theories and what
could happen in the film throughout this
video I'll be breaking down the top five
bad theories that I've read and
discussing if I think that they hold any
weight this is full spoilers ahead so if
you haven't seen endgame yet and don't
want to know some of the big pop points
from that film then I highly suggest
that you turn off now with that out the
way I hope you enjoy the video now sit
back relax and let's get into my far
from home fan theories breakdown theory
one Tony Stark will be in the movie okay
so the first fan theory comes in the
form of a returning character who was
seemingly killed off in endgame whilst I
do believe that Tony Stark is dead that
doesn't mean that he won't be in the
film in one form or another in endgame
we saw that Stark left not one but two
farewell messages to his friends and
family so it makes sense that he would
also leave something behind for Peter
Parker
while Stoney will not be in the film
through flesh and blood I do think that
we will see a return of the character
through the form of a hologram which
Peter will discover when putting on his
glasses in the trailer we see him taking
them off and seeming surprised at what
he's just witnessed so it makes sense
for Tony to have left something special
behind for him whilst the two did get an
opportunity to say goodbye to each other
it still would be a nice little Easter
Egg that shows that in one form or
another
Tony will always be with him theory to
Mysterio is lying on X fan Theory
centers around Mysterio of the newly
introduced MCU character whilst Mysterio
claims to be from another dimension I
don't actually think that
is true many fans online including
myself believe that the elementals in
the film are in fact illusions that the
character is using in order to propel
himself as a savior adding a mysterious
universe to his past will also help to
avoid suspicion about how he came to
achieve his abilities and therefore most
will probably not look into it saying
he's from the multiverse is the perfect
opportunity for the character to put
himself at the forefront and if he's
lying about the elementals and he can
bet that he's also lying about where he
comes from however I do think that the
multi Buddhist is still real and will be
in the MCU I think the two post-credit
scenes of the film will have some major
moments that we'll pull from this and
that ties into my next theory theory 3
the movie will have an x-men tie-in
x-men Dark Phoenix is due to release in
June and the film is said to be the
conclusion of the x-men Fox franchise
Disney now owns the studio and therefore
the x-men characters so spider-man far
from home is the perfect opportunity to
bring the two universes together
especially now that we know the
multiverse exists I believe that during
one of the film's post-credit scenes
that we will get a tie-in to the x-men
franchise with some of the characters
crossing over into the universe if not
this then definitely the Fantastic Four
who are long overdue to appear in the
MCU the snap tearing through reality is
the perfect opportunity to introduce
already established characters and
Marvel will likely be bringing them in
too far from home which is going to act
as huge setup for phase 4 there's also
been massive rumors about reshoots
around x-men doc Phoenix and I think the
final act of that film will tease is
tie-in to the MCU through the use of the
multiverse Disney have a big opportunity
to bring two massive franchises together
and the fact that they are introducing
the multiverse confirms to me at least
that they are definitely going to bring
the two together in a crossover theory
for spider-man hua is from the
multiverse
whilst I'm not fully on board with this
theory I think that it could be an
interesting way to introduce the spider
verse into the MCU that film was
obviously very successful and Sony will
be wanting to cash in on it as much as
possible therefore there is a chance
that the black suit spider-man that we
see in the trailer isn't actually Peter
Parker
Earth Prime and his in fact is
spider-man from an alternate timeline
that's battling the elementals though
there isn't much evidence for this
beyond guesswork it would still be a
neat way to showcase the rest of the
multiverse and give us an awesome
alternative version of spider-man in the
process Theory 5mj is Nick Fury's
daughter and finally this is probably
the most widespread theory that I've
seen online and regards to the film and
many seem to believe that this is indeed
true including myself but what evidence
is there for this well character wise
the two actually have a lot in common
MJ is always spying and creeping up on
people and she literally goes a
detention to profile and draw portraits
of other classmates outfit-wise the two
characters share similar tastes
with both donning black for the majority
of their appearances MJ's hair covers
her right eye a lot in homecoming
similar to Nick Fury's eye patch and
despite being anti Authority she still
ends up a leader at the end of the film
historically parents always play a big
role in the spider-man universe and over
the decades we've saw Harry Osborn's
father as the Green Goblin Gwen Stacy's
as the chief of police and Liz's as the
vulture this would open up an amazing
opportunity for Nick Fury to become the
stern father and would add an extra
layer to his relationship with Peter
that would no doubt be hilarious in the
film I can definitely see this being the
case and I really hope that this makes
it to the movie oh yeah and that would
explain how she also knows that Peter
Parker is spider-man
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on these fan theories and if you agree
or disagree with them comment below and
let me know and if you love this video
3000 then please like it and make sure
you check out my full trailer breakdown
which will be linked at the end it
covers everything you need to know about
the far from home trailer and I go over
my theory on how Sony will use it as a
platform to bring Tom Hollands webhead
into the spider bed this is a channel
for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like it's a
Cripe thanks again for taking the time
to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]